okay so this video is going to be on
plant evolution you know some of the
basic patterns that we've uncovered
about plants and and their
characteristics so let's go ahead and
get started so when we start off with
plant evolution we have to really go
back about 450 million years ago to a
group of green algae so the group of the
pictures that you see you have some
green algae on the left and in the
primitive plant it's actually moss right
there on the right but there is a group
of green algae called Carl fights and
Carl fights appear to have a lot in
common with the most primitive plants at
the time from what we can tell from DNA
evidence and in fossils and and even the
more primitive plants that are still
alive today
and for instance we see that Carl fights
and very primitive plants they're both
multicellular they both contain the same
types of chlorophyll you know there's
different types of chlorophyll needed to
do photosynthesis and Carl fights and
early plants have those same types each
of the green algae Carl fights and early
primitive plants they store their energy
as start you know the through
photosynthesis they'll make sugar and
then that sugar is converted into starch
as a stored source of energy both have
cellulose in their cell walls and this
is a common feature between the green
algae ancestors and primitive plants and
also both reproduce with sperm and egg
so in order to reproduce sexually they
produce sperm cells that will swim and
fertilized egg and to make a zygote and
and so yes Carl fights green algae and
early primitive plants have sperm that
actually swim through water in order to
reproduce so when we look at the plant
evolution like I said up you know
earlier moment ago mosses are some of
the earliest most primitive plants that
are still alive on earth today and when
you look at some very big
features of moths there they're very
small growing they don't grow very tall
off the ground and they're nonvascular
we'll explain what that means in a
moment but these are some very basic
features of moss and and tracing back to
their ancestry about 450 million years
ago you know in this diagram here we
kind of see of the fie logic
phylogenetic history of plants from
there green algae ancestor mosses being
the most primitive that are kind of
around today and then you see the
evolution of a vascular system which
leads to ferns gymnosperms and
angiosperms
well ferns are a little different from
angiosperms and gymnosperms because
ferns are seed seedless they don't make
seeds but gymnosperms and angiosperms do
so how did gymnosperms and angiosperms
differ well it's really how they produce
their seeds gymnosperms produce their
seeds and cones and angiosperms are the
names of plants that make flowers and
fruits so it's a nice little diagram
that kind of traces the phylogenetic
history of plants that we see on earth
today so when we look at plants you know
plants live on land for the most part
and green algae were mostly aquatic so
in order to live life on land there
there had to be some challenges that had
to be overcome for instance living on
land presents a big challenge moisture
in order to survive on land you have to
have a way to retain moisture you know
in the animation we have a plant leaf
hair losing water through the process
called transpiration and if this plant
loses too much water it will dehydrate
and die so there has to be a way for
plants to maintain their their water
levels and when we look at where we find
evidence of early plant life you know
early plant life grew along you know
water's edge rivers lakes streams oceans
where moisture was more abundant
but when we look today you know plants
today have colonized most habitats on
land so in order to achieve that they
had to find a way to overcome water loss
and so a couple of the solutions I want
to mention one of them are called still
not a tiny microscopic pores usually on
the backside of leaves and these pores
can open and close to allow gas exchange
in the picture here's a zoomed in
magnified view of a Stowe mate still
mate this singular stomata is plural and
when open the Stowe mate will take in
gases such as carbon dioxide and will
release oxygen that it makes through
photosynthesis now when the the Stowe
mate is closed like it is in this
picture right here water is less likely
to escape through evaporation so by
having these pores and the ability to
open and close them they're able to
regulate some of their water loss
another way to regulate water loss is by
having their leaves covered in a layer
of wax and plant leaves are covered in a
layer of waxy a waxy coating called the
cuticle and here's a great picture here
that shows us the matter or a still mate
and you can see the criss crossing of
the wax buildup on this picture right
here on this on this leaf and it's a way
to trap water on the inside so they are
less likely to dry out wonderful
adaptations to survive on land another
land adaptation another challenge to add
to life on land I want to mention is
trim the ability to transport nutrients
and resource you know plans can be
really really tall and they have that
will have a way to transport nutrients
and water from the ground where their
roots are to the treetops for instance
and so a solution that has evolved over
time is a vascular system a vascular
system is kind of like the circulatory
system that animals have a vascular
system is a way to transport nutrients
throughout the entire plant throughout
the entire organism and so if we zoom on
into this tree trunk let's go ahead and
do that so here is a tree trunk and if
we look you know inside we see these
little tubes and these are part of the
vascular system you may have heard of
the xylem and the phloem and you know
maybe perhaps middle school classes well
through these tubes through the blue
ones called the xylem a water for
instance will will will come up from the
roots the roots will absorb water and
water which will travel up these xylem
tubes and ultimately reach the tree tops
where the cells up there need water so
it's a great way for them to transport
water distances well the other tubes the
pink ones in this case labeled the
phloem and there are tubes and again
sugars which are created through
photosynthesis in the treetops in the
leaves at the top of the tree sugars
will be sent down these tubes to the
lower parts of the plants and therefore
the all the cells of the tree are able
to get nutrition and so there's a great
picture kind of showing the the tubes
kind of a cross-section here showing the
tubes of the vascular system and through
these tubes water and sugars and other
nutrients can travel and be transported
throughout the entire plant and so the
vascular system is really allowed a
plant life to to grow to greater heights
you know in this picture here here's a
picture of Moss Moss is a primitive
nonvascular plants it doesn't have a
vascular system but you look at redwood
trees for instance redwood trees are
vascular and there's a reason why they
are the tallest organisms on earth you
know a couple hundred feet tall our
redwood trees and they have vascular
tubes to transport nutrients
so while we're on the topic of height
with the picture of the redwood tree
want to mention another land challenge
and the ability to grow upright you know
under water your body weight is
supported you know if you ever play you
know games and a swimming pool with
friends and you're picking friends up
underwater your friends are very easy to
pick up underwater because water
supports weight but that same friend
that was very easy to pick up underwater
is very difficult to pick up outside of
water so a water supports weight and if
trees like this can live on land they
have to have a way to support their own
weight
yes plants have roots which which grow
throughout the ground and help support
them but an analogy I want to make here
is the brick wall you know in there's
cement in between every brick to help
hold the wall up and that's called
mortar well the analogy I want to make
to mortar is what's called lignin lignin
is a molecule that help helps the cell
wall of plants Harden and it's what
gives what its strength and when you
look at this picture here we have
hundreds of cells right here tightly
compacted together with each cell wall
hardened and stiff made up of lignin
which again look kind of like the mortar
in between the bricks so one way that
trees can grow so tall besides having a
vascular system is they have little
cements in between their cells called
lignin so living on land we already
mentioned that has presented some
problems for plants you know wind can
topple an organism over or dry it out
retaining moisture is a problem exposure
to UV support so you can grow tall but
we haven't really mentioned how plants
reproduce on land you know organisms
like animals that reproduce in the water
what often happens is the male's will
release sperm into the ocean water for
instance and females will release eggs
into the ocean water and the sperm and
eggs will just mix with one another and
fertilization will occur but on land
there's really no
water to swim through now some plants
actually like mosses we mentioned mosses
some plants actually do reproduce on
land with swimming sperm cells ma simply
reproduce after its rained and there's a
layer of water on the ground but many
plants aren't like that
so reproducing on land without the use
of water is a challenge and many plants
have overcome that challenge with a few
neat little adaptations one of they're
one of their solutions is the evolution
of pollen pollen is simply many times
released into the air and travels with
the wind or pollen can be spread by
animals here's a microscopic image of
pollen and in this picture here you can
see a gentleman is kind of shaking the
branches of a tree and dust is coming
out of these cones that you see and that
dust is pollen you know many people have
allergies to pollen in this case the
pollen is just being spread through the
air and through the wind in some cases
like you see in this picture here this
bumble bee is covered in a yellow dust
and that yellow dust is pollen this
bumble bee will fly from flower to
flower to flower feeding on nectar but
at the same time spreading pollen and so
these are two ways in which pollen is
transferred I want to look at the bumble
bee example in a little more detail so
here we have flower flower number one
and it's got four structures that
produce pollen the red dots are supposed
to be powered and what happens is a
bumble bee will come around and buzz
around the flower and you know feed off
of the neck there and as it's buzzing
around it gets that red pollen all over
its body and then flies away well you
know let's follow that bumble bee
so nearby flower number one is flower
number two and here comes the bumble bee
last time we saw at a moment ago it was
covered in pollen and the bumble bees
just doing the same thing well you know
rocking it walking around flower number
two and as it does some of the pollen
that was attached to its body falls onto
flower number two and
is pollination so this is one way that
plants have have adapted to life on land
is through the use of pollinating
animals such as bumblebees
well another adaptation help them
reproduce on land is the evolution of
seeds you know here's an avocado seed in
the picture a seed is a has a hard
protective coat but inside the seed
there's an actual embryo when we look at
this little drawing here of an avocado
seed
yeah the outside has a hard protective
coat but inside there's a bunch of
nutrition for the embryo to feed off of
eventually the seed will crack open and
the embryo will have little tiny leaves
and it's able to do photosynthesis but
inside of a seed is an embryo and it's a
way in wherever seeds eventually settle
on the ground hopefully the seed will
will continue to grow and and and sprout
into a new plant you know one of the
defining features of plants is it is a
life cycle that plants go through called
alternation of generations where plants
alternate between the haploid and
diploid stage in in their life cycles
and this is a very generic diagram but
this is a diagram that's fairly true of
all plants if we look at the zygote at
this point in the school year I hope you
know that it would a zygote is it's a
fertilized egg created from the fusion
in the union of a sperm and egg cell so
a zygote follow the arrow will divide by
mitosis and grow into something called a
sporophyte so the sporophyte is simply
the adult name for the diploid stage in
the life of a plant so an adult
sporophyte
in depending on the plant it could take
decades for a sporophyte to reach
adulthood some plants go through there
go through life in one year other plants
can live for decades and decades so in
the named sporophyte I hope you see the
prefix for the words for so plants
create something called spores and if
you follow the arrow to the left spores
are created through the process of
meiosis
so therefore spores are going to be
haploid and so haploid spores are
created by meiosis and so now we've
entered the haploid stage in the
alternation of generations that plants
exhibit where they spend half third and
not half excuse me
they spend part of their lifecycle as a
diploid organism and part of their life
as a haploid
so those haploid spores will land in the
ground and the spores will grow some
spores will grow into what's called a
male gametophyte other spores will grow
into what's called a female gametophyte
so of some spores when they land on the
ground will grow into the male
gametophyte as I just mentioned and
others for is when they land on the
ground will grow into the female
gametophyte now in the word gametophyte
there's a prefix for the word gamete and
so the male gametophyte will create the
male gamete which is called sperm the
female gametophyte will create the
female gamete which is called an egg and
so I hope you see what we're setting up
we're setting up the bringing together
of egg and sperm from the gametophyte
the male gametophyte releases sperm the
female gametophyte makes an egg and now
we're back to where we started the sperm
and the egg will fuse and in
fertilization will occur to create a
diploid zygote the zygote again is
diploid so the zygote marks the
beginning of the diploid stage again and
that zygote will then grow into another
another sporophyte and the whole cycle
repeats itself so when we look at the
ecology of plants memory ecology is
studying how life interacts with the
environment plants are often in a
mutualistic relationship with another
organism now the picture doesn't show
plants it's just a classic example of
mutualism involving a clownfish that
lives amongst the tentacles of an
anemone so the clownfish benefits by
getting a home and protection the
clownfish can also feed off of the
leftover food scraps of the anemone the
anemone benefits because the anemone is
also protected from smaller
invertebrates by the clownfish and it
will also feed off of the feast
of the clownfish so it's a great example
of mutualism where both benefit well but
what about plants let's look at a great
example of mutualism involving bacteria
and plants so in this picture here were
zoomed in and in this picture here it
shows the roots of of legumes like beans
and notice how those little bumps or
nodules these are little growths of
bacteria these nodules and when they
grow amongst the roots of plant so we
have two organisms living together here
we have plants and we have bacteria
let's explain how this is mutualistic so
the reason this is a mutualistic
relationship is the bacteria supply
ammonia that the plant desperately needs
the plants roots will take in the
ammonia and grow what about the bacteria
the bacteria benefits because it will
the plant supplies nutrients
particularly produced through
photosynthesis that the bacteria needs
to survive so it's a great example of a
mutualistic relationship with plants
excuse me with plants and bacteria so
kind of a more classic example of
mutualism involving plants is a
relationship between plants and
pollinating animals in this case the
plant supplies food or nectar for
whoever the pollinator is whether it's
bumble bee whether it's hummingbird and
in the picture here you see it's a
butterfly so the plant supplies food
what about the pollinator the pollinator
spreads pollen for the plant as the
pollinator flies from flower to flower
to flower it spreads pollen and achieves
pollination in order for the plant to
reproduce so again a classic example of
mutualism well let's not forget that
plants have to defend themselves against
herbivore predators and plants have all
kinds of adaptations to defend
themselves against herbivores
spines thorns chemicals to fight off
herbivores you know in the picture here
here's a cactus and you can see all the
thorns that surround the
yes and if you're a hungry herbivore
you're probably going to have a hard
time eating this plant and so you'll
choose to eat another plant that is less
protected so I've got a wonderful
adaptation in order to defend themselves
against herbivores you know I grew up in
Illinois and I had to be very wary of
poison ivy forever playing baseball or
throwing a frisbee around and the ball
or the frisbee lands in a patch of
poison ivy you have to know what it
looks like and the same if you haven't
heard it before is called leaves of
three let it be here we see the the
telltale signal of poison ivy these
three leaves grouped together and if you
ever do reach in to get the baseball and
get the frisbee well you might come down
with with a real nasty rash couple days
later so really itchy it's not
life-threatening but my point is that
poison ivy is is is poisonous again not
poisonous the point where a person is
going to die but herbivores become weary
of eating plants that get them sick or
that could give them a really nasty rash
and so it's a great defense mechanism
against herbivores so there you go
there's the end of this video
you know if you're in my biology class
pause the video try to answer these
questions and I'd be happy to check your
answers before school or after school
one day so go ahead and pause the video
and good luck